who is your favorite influencer who is
your favorite influences that's a trap
question it's a trap question is you're
an influencer aren't you I don't have to
be a favorite influencing you're my
favorite personal influencer all right
then
oh I like you the best ah there's love
but actually my very first one I think
was actually Eric Thomas oh okay
Aramis yeah Eric Thomason is famous
speech yeah the the drowning the kid one
yeah yeah so that one got me a lot when
I was growing up and then obviously Gary
Vee came into the picture yeah life by
then so Gary Vee play a big part and
then um with you so now I got your ex
influenced every day you go right every
day every day we should me every day
right uh who would I pick I think early
on as a as a speaker a young Les Brown
is my hero I love young Les Brown but I
don't know that he's really neat Flynn
sir it's probably not what the question
was
it's a young Les Brown and then now
influencers I would probably put it
between Gary and Tom I like Gary and Tom
yeah yeah Gary's got the the I mean
Tom's got the hustle and all that stuff
too yeah Gary just yells more here's in
your face and yes I like that I like
that actually you know what my my most
recently found one was David Goggins Oh
Goggins is off dog gargons is parkour
but he's not really an influencer no but
he's inspiring is that count I guess I
guess I mean he has a book here's a book
dropping old is he next month
oh yeah coming out I got the first book
yeah it's amazing
Tom what I love about Tom is he's always
shown in his early days yeah and like
his goofy ears and yeah
and everybody's only pumping out like
how good they are and it's showing how
much he sucked yeah and then when he
launched his comic book
he's showing pictures of him setting up
the booth himself yeah you know like
he's still he's made he so humbles made
his money yeah and he is humble but you
know Gary's humble too Gary's very hope
I like that's what I like about him but
Tom will show the humbleness yeah he'll
show it where where people will ridicule
him say why are you setting that up you
got all this money what are you doing
are you yeah or like when look at those
goofy years like you say yeah yeah so
that that little that extra a little bit
about Tom is whereas Goggins is very
like tough-guy Man of Steel yeah yeah
Goggin like you're weak you don't do
this yeah thing which they have their
place and so here's the I think I think
I like Gary for you too but I like Tom
for Instagram yeah no I that's where we
go cuz Thomas to show that side on
YouTube yeah Tom has the he's got his
interviews which are always great yeah
and then he's got his his yelling like
he his motivational like grants yeah
yeah right business showed that that
other side so I like I like Tom Tom bill
you Instagram maze and Gary Vee YouTube
tips on how to prioritize tasks Dana
what do you got you want mister of
course this baby never show babies and
that's only good self about it cool I
don't know why we just decided
prioritize tasks well they're all
important because I think when you love
something you're passionate about
everything's important watch our phones
like the phones like right there okay
okay so yeah like I said I think
everything is important every little
thing is important in terms of priority
honestly I think it's just a matter of
just getting down and doing it I don't
think okay but you have a list like you
have a list I always have a list yeah so
we've got we've got a bunch of stuff we
have to do before we even with leave
yeah but I don't how do you prioritize
besides me say and he day me has this
Friday coming along I said do it that's
it like you literally just do it like I
go home I'm like oh but how do you know
what to do if you've got 20 things how
do you pick that this is what I'm gonna
work on tonight you got to pick one and
you just got to do it but how do you
pick that one well it depends what
you're doing
right so for me okay it's video editing
there's video editing and then there's
like sorting and and and doing all that
like preparing footage and backing up
footage and organizing footage so
there's a lot of different steps
yeah right I know so projects with
deadlines so what I have to do is pick
one project right that's just based off
of deadlines deadlines really yeah at
the end of the day well you set your own
deadlines or it's all I always well
there's always deadlines given to me
yeah but then I would always always pick
a deadline faster than that like I
always wanted to finish a little bit
earlier than I'm supposed to okay then
that allows me to
makes prioritizing easier when you're
not always on the edge right and you're
always like picking things you know done
last minute right type of thing so okay
so most of those deadlines are our
customer driven right like saying if
anybody's ever been calm but then you
have your own which you should always
put ahead of your your customers right
but that's still a customer driven
deadline right like it's we need this
video done by Tuesday so you want to get
it done by Sunday exactly yeah but the
who decided to x' day was still the
client yeah how do you fit your own your
own other stuff in the schedule so like
you know it's so part of our deal was
you're gonna make your own movie yeah
how we're gonna fit that in I mean we've
got our tour coming up before crazy yeah
yeah but then we get back yeah how you
gonna fit in I think I think it's just
you have to prioritize your life like in
terms everything else outside of what
you're supposed to do okay right if you
prioritize that it makes your job much
easier so how do I prioritize my life I
think it's something where like you just
have to you have to plan ahead you have
to buy the creative schedule some people
like to write it down some people like
to I don't know whatever ways people do
it right for me I like to go week by
week right so in that week I'm a more of
a tell myself thing type of guy so every
morning tell myself like you know
remember Tuesday you have this ones you
have this Thursday have this Friday have
this so a so you wake up and and you say
and and I always tell myself what do I
have today and what I have tomorrow
would have the next day and then another
week yeah for a week oh you look at what
you're doing for the week and you tell
you everyday is how you start your day
all the time wow that's wild okay so
then I go Wednesday I'm like what do I
have today Thursday Friday Saturday so
Kay okay right and it's just like it's
constant for me writing things down I
lose pieces of paper all the time okay
so that doesn't work for me or like if
it's in a book I won't open it cuz I
don't know what a book is sorry if I
don't find in the first 30 seconds
forget about it so how do you remember
what you did what you would use I never
said it's just up here yeah I mean
usually you wake up this morning you're
like okay it's Monday I got what I got
to do I got to come that and then
Tuesday this is what I'm gonna do from
memory you sitting like I you lying in
bed you thinking about this I never
stopped thinking about it but like I
know I know it's crazy the moment you
wake up you're thinking here's what I
need to do this yes and it's from memory
yeah
but like again like my life is very
simple like Nina asked me yesterday
night yeah well my hobbies were no
answers right right so like I either
work workout sleep or eat like a that's
all I do
so like for me I don't crowd my life
with a lot of other things okay so it's
it's easier for me to do that right
whereas I know I understand people have
children people families they have
priorities with other things and it's a
little bit more difficult that can't
answer for that because yeah I don't
have that so for me it's easier for me
to do that like it's nonstop for me
that's how I operate but for me I like
like I said if you prioritize your life
outside of work what you need to do
right need to have a balance of both
then prioritizing your work it is much
easier and you got to sacrifice a little
bit on both in order to make it work
so I like having different things on
different days I think you need to
schedule for success where you need to
understand that your to-do list will
never will never full to go away your
ideas list will just continue to balloon
yeah well we'll never you'll never hit
everything like this and your yeah and
as you have more success you'll get more
ideas and so I understand the challenge
of how do I pick on my ideas list right
so here's what I do one I have a
different task for a different day so
Monday is my mentoring day so I'm work
with the people my team to help them get
better as you build a company I've got
24 people on my team now you recognize
that your contribution isn't as strong
as everybody else in the business so
individually yes I bring the most but
collectively my team does way more than
I do and so the more they're growing the
better the business grows so Monday's
mentoring day Tuesday has been the whole
day doing YouTube stuff Wednesdays
project day I'm launching my two new
books and working on the tour Thursday's
public facing day Friday see ya so
public facing day is interviews hangouts
podcasts Fridays CEO day working on big
projects to grow the business saturday
is husband wife time spending the time
with Nina planning surprises for her all
day
and then Sunday is family admin day
shopping cleaning up and min stuff for
the family
and then I repeat and so that when I
look at it on a macro I look down and
like that is something that I'm excited
by so these are the big things that are
happening in my life and I always
designed my schedule around it then
within it how do I pick you know so when
I'm doing YouTube great I have to make
my twenty whatever videos a week so I'm
sitting there recording but then I'm
doing experiments on thumbnails and
titles and new series and trying to do
new things always for the channel to
make it blow up and grow and also just
exciting but it's nice to try different
things for myself and I just picked the
idea that I like the most you know like
I have some that I have to get done so
like use our schedule for YouTube and I
have to make my top tens my espresso and
whatever and then the rest of the day is
gonna be YouTube stuff I'll just look at
my list of ideas and say that one I like
I like the ones that you feel most
connected to even in the moment are the
ones that you'll bring the best energy
to yeah absolutely yeah right and so you
might have you might have a list of all
sorts of different editing techniques
that you've seen from Netflix Docs yeah
okay you know what I want to try that
one today all the time yeah exactly yeah
you pick that why don't you go yeah yeah
so I think I think when you wake up and
you have no idea what to do I think that
actually is not great I think for I
think having some structure is good for
you I think I think I think the people
who hate structure need need if you get
some structure it would actually save
your life and make you a lot happier and
the people who are over structured need
to have a little bit of openness and
some variety in their schedule so I
think if you can sit down and look at a
macro for your week what I want to do in
different days and then within it there
will be deadlines it will be some
project you have to work on but then you
have some freedom to pick I like that
idea
I'm gonna go chase it yeah the faster
you can go from idea to testing it
trying it the better the better yeah
double down double down on something
that you're good at getting some
momentum with or diversify what do you
think oh man that's your specialty but
I'll give my opinion dani and evan jesus
a specialist in this in this regard I
guess I can kind of relate to my genre
in terms of my industry being in the
videography business personally I think
you need to double down on on what your
niches so as a videographer like III at
first I tried to challenge myself by say
I'm gonna do weddings and I'm gonna do
sports and then I'm gonna do this and
I'm do some and any [ __ ] just became
so big because there's so many different
little differences in everything that
you do that when you try to do
everything at once it's easy to burn out
easy to to just be overwhelmed so I
think it's best is find your niche start
with that build your skills within that
niche and then let then expand it to
other things as you get better
I think people diversify themselves out
of the business yeah I think I think
diversification is a fantastic
investment strategy mmm but it sucks as
an entrepreneurship strategy for
everybody who's trying to build multiple
streams of income and they haven't even
built one yet yeah it's a losing it's a
losing game I agree it's a losing
mindset like a build your one stream and
make it awesome and then worry about
building a second stream I think
everybody you know what social media
network should I start on and they try
to be everywhere and then you do all of
them really poorly yeah yeah to think
that you can run a business and then
also have a youtube channel on Instagram
and Twitter and snapchat and Facebook
and LinkedIn and Pinterest and you can't
so I mean you came but it's gonna be
garbage everywhere pick one where your
were one your audience is and two you
feel most connected to and then go all
in on that so it was YouTube for me I've
always had one I mean I've had my
history but YouTube is my main thing
right now and now I'm starting to get
into Instagram yo a little hardcore but
I've got 24 people on my team right like
I wouldn't be able to do everything all
myself and I think that applies not just
to social media but to the business yeah
if you're trying to take on every single
customer if you're trying to serve every
industry if you just diversify yourself
out of a business most people diversify
themselves out of the business
and one of my favorite quotes on this is
from Andrew Carnegie who's the richest
man in America who said put all your
eggs in one basket and then watch that
basket and I think when it's your
business so it's not just relying on
somebody else but like it's your
business then diversification is not the
best strategy diversification is a great
investment strategy don't worry about
building multiple streams of income
until you've built one and made it
awesome then you can worry about the
next yeah then I think goes back to the
first question of prioritizing right
it's gonna be so much harder prioritize
when you have to worry about your
YouTube video Instagram LinkedIn
whatever it is you're doing all of it
and you're just gonna you didn't be -
it's it's gonna be too much yeah I mean
I'm still I'm focused on those two and I
want and it's a lot yeah that's a lot to
do it well yeah like before setting up
and going live where I'm on my phone
answering Instagram DMS cuz I'm already
I'm already feeling massively behind
yeah be able to answer everybody's
Instagram DM so if I'm struggling to
make it quality and I'm not looking at
the next thing yet whoever asked the
question like yeah what's your excuse
right and I think if you can if you can
and people say okay what happens when
Instagram goes away what happens when
YouTube goes away like you're putting
all your eggs in one basket in the
YouTube basket and then it disappears
it's the wrong way to look at it because
one you build skills mmm
you build skill set right and two you
built a brand name that is transferable
so what happened when vine went away
well the Paul Brothers came to YouTube
and destroyed it you always bring your
following with you and your skills
skills right like better if you get
amazing at making YouTube videos from an
editor yeah and YouTube blows up yeah it
goes away like it's gone Elon Musk buys
it and shuts
the platform great you know how to make
killer videos exactly yeah
there's gonna be something else then you
can nose apply your skills to exactly so
if Instagram and YouTube went away I
could take my skills and bring it
somewhere else because I've spent all
that time honing that skill and getting
good at it so the Paul brothers come
from shut down vine to YouTube and
destroy it mm-hmm because they had an
audience but they had the skills yeah
yeah and so people would say well don't
put all your eggs in the vine basket put
all your eggs in the vine basket and if
it goes away go crush somewhere else
as opposed to having little pieces
everywhere and you suck in everything
anything yeah you never could get
anything
yeah and applies to not just social
media but have your life my business
yeah yeah and everything in life
relationships whatever it is like it
could break up you can you can if you're
trying to do 18 different diets at the
same time yeah it's not gonna happen
yeah you're gonna suck at all of those
hard enough yeah keto alone is harder
now what is harder now it's hard enough
do you want but I don't think people
want to do one thing well it'll get
bored and then it gets hard
yeah to get really good you can get okay
good quickly and so it's fun and you
learn a new thing but when it gets hard
it's to get mastery at something yeah
it's a lot of work yeah people that want
to do that that's all you're like what's
the next thing
mmm I I think then you never actually
get gains anyway
that is best video editing software I
use Adobe Premiere if you're on PC Final
Cut works great for Mac and DaVinci
Resolve is amazing
for color so it's pretty much those
three are the industry standards
nowadays so I would say only listen to
that answer if you want to be great at
video editing as your business yeah
that's true I started in well it doesn't
exist anymore but Macromedia flash which
was made for like presentations and
stuff and now it's plop like pictures in
video I think people focus on the wrong
thing
yeah I started with Windows Movie Maker
and then Camtasia little-ass my first
user but here's the thing this is a
problem but I love Bo Bo Bo's Bo's
amazing Bo's Bo's come out to the
workshop he's coming to the next one
who's leading the session for us yeah Bo
asked great questions and Bo has a way
of slur too has a way of getting the
people that that I haven't seen before
bo bo we got to get this guy to see Oh
Bo with hockey Eric Arnold Arnold we got
to get in see Arnold but but Bo should
not be worried about editing software
should not be worrying about what the
best is because Bo should not want to be
the best editor right right it's not a
good use of time this is what frustrates
me but what a lot of thought leaders is
you spend 20 minutes recording the video
practicing your message and hopefully
get that down to a five minute video
with 20 minutes of recording in it and
then you spend 4 hours editing it yeah
you're spending way more time on the
scale that you don't want to be the best
in the world that instead of focusing on
hey I want to be a great speaker mm-hmm
hey I want to be a great thought leader
so I was working on how to speak yes
then those four hours yeah it should be
flipped yeah it should be 4 hours
practicing so that you learn how to give
a good fire five minute piece of content
because that's a skill you take forever
into whatever platform comes up next
yeah serves you for life but the editing
skill is not something that
want to be world-class at so you want to
spend 20 minutes on it yeah you're using
anything to save you from not being a
great speaker yeah which is why when I
speak that's one one or two takes five
minutes folks don't even think about it
but yeah absolutely but I spend like
hours and hours editing and then
practicing like nobody's coming to you
for your editing skills and you don't
want to be great editor now I respect
that's why I have Danny you know like I
respect the craft I think it's important
I think what Danny can do was amazing
and definitely miles ahead of whatever I
could ever do ever but I can't speak
like you hear you can't be like you so
but how do you get to tell you well
that's great like you hired how do you
get to hire an editor you have to be
great the thing that you do yeah right
you you will never get to hire a Danny
if you are spending four hours at it in
a video and thirty minutes recording it
yeah you just
you'll never get you'll never build your
business up high enough because you're
not spending enough time on the craft
that will actually get you notice which
is you're speaking or you're singing
mm-hmm or you're rapping or you're
playing the piano or whatever videos are
making mm-hmm where it's better to spend
all that time learning how to be able to
make a great five to ten minute piece of
content of you just speaking in one take
so that you don't need a lot of editing
that's the skill to work on yeah and
then you get noticed and then you can
hire an editor to make it look even
better and bring in motion graphics and
fancy music and intro and outro and all
that kind of stuff yeah yeah exactly
people on your craft that spend your
time schooled on your craft absolutely
and not all the related stuff hundred
percent yeah you gotta get good back to
the mastery question you got to get good
at it
you got to be a master at something yeah
I spend your time on that and goes back
to a diversity question do you diversify
do you you know double down on something
as an editor I don't focus on the visual
effects and stuff like that because
that's a whole other career
I focus on what I'm good at which is
telling the story which is an editing so
I don't go and I don't try to overwhelm
myself with you know how do I compose
green screens and imaginary dragons
flying across the screen and things like
that like I work on telling my stories
I'm gonna eventually hire someone to do
that for me we definitely need some
dragons it's flooding our videos Amy
Adam it may be someone goes yeah I'm
disappointed off dragons flying around
so yeah no that's absolutely 100% you
want to be an entrepreneur go into the
military be good I know nothing about
the military okay except that maybe it
can help my only assumption is that
gonna help build a strong mindset and I
hope you also build Oh get physical I
think for uh having a healthy physical
lifestyle helps you being entrepreneur I
think taking care of your body is big
part of taking care of your mind take
care of your mind you can think better
you can operate better so I mean that's
the only benefit I can think of but I
don't really know anything about the
military so I I'm not too sure how to
answer that question yeah I mean I'm not
I'm not in military either I haven't
done service we don't have to do service
in Canada yeah and and so we're in
Canada yeah and and the Canadian
military is also not like a huge part of
the culture yeah
that being said whatever you want to
learn something go learn from the people
who are doing the thing could you learn
how to be an entrepreneur and take some
of the skills absolutely right but could
you learn how to be an entrepreneur from
an entrepreneur yeah way better
Yeah right like if you want to learn you
know how to how to eat right you wanna
learn how to take care of your body is
joining the military gonna help you
probably but you could probably get
their life faster by going to a
nutritionist in a personal trainer yeah
that's true dude does it translate into
what you want to do so I think a lot of
it will translate but it's just so it's
you're not actually hitting the target
yeah you're shooting an arrow and you're
hitting like all around the target
instead of going to the target yeah so
can you learn yes but is it is it the
best use of your time
probably not right like I would try to
go work for an entrepreneur if that's
your ambition right
and what if it's a necessity for people
so like the military's like it's an
option for a career it can make them a
little bit of money you can get them
some free education would you say that I
think if you want to be an entrepreneur
I wouldn't go to the military okay if
you want a career if you love your
country if you love the idea of
defending freedom and you get an
education and then it's and you love the
brotherhood or sisterhood and you love
the discipline and you you know you love
being in shape all the time and all of
the stuff that you get from being in the
military yeah you look pride you love
your country great that's why you go to
the military but going as a building
block to build your own entrepreneurship
is not a good idea that's what you're
saying
I think I think is just a slow path
right go direct okay yeah just go direct
yeah
like if you want to learn video editing
go work for Video Editor mm-hmm
you could learn a lot doing some I don't
know where it's video kind of you know
like if you came and work for me doing
you know outreach for my tour or
something but you really wanted to be a
video editor you learn a little bit like
you'll hang around Danny you'll you'll
see how we do some videos but you'll
spend most your time doing how to run a
tour yeah because that's what you were
hired to do yeah words better the go
work for somebody who is a full-time
video editor mm-hmm and go learn from
them you'll just learn so much faster
like in three months you'll learn what
you can learn in four years mm-hmm
yeah and that's what you want yeah so
aim for like the major goal just hit the
target hit the target hit that major
goal instead of hitting the goals that
can keep you around it I guess losing
yeah
how do you differentiate your product
from your competitors Danny what do we
got
let's get some value here this might
just be from videographer I don't know
it all applies everywhere for me it's
just I think if you just put your
passion into your work it will be
different I think when you try to copy
everybody else and you try to just look
at everything else and be like I'm gonna
do foot print everybody and put it into
you know one piece of work it doesn't
you know you lose that personal touch I
think when you when you love something
and you put your passion your love into
it
it just it will just be like I don't
think you should try to think about hey
what's my what's my style like I don't
think you ever think about that I think
you just do it and then you realize oh
wow okay so this is my style and through
time it just kind of evolves and might
change it might you know go a different
way but at the end of the day I think
that's how you differentiate I think you
just have to worry about getting the
work done and and and putting love into
it nice yeah I think I think at the
beginning you should copy and steal
everything I think I think if you're in
video you should you should look at
Steven Spielberg and the Netflix is
influenced though rather think no I
would like straight-up copy straight-up
know at the beginning okay Oh cut the
beginning I would straight up like when
you're you're sorry sorry Berg did this
yeah I want to do that and straight up
do the exact try you won't you won't
suck at the beginning course but but you
try and then you see like okay just like
when you go to art school they say you
know draw this picture mm-hmm and you
try and you do your best I think I think
that's good I think that helps you
figure out what you like doing I think
if you saw some effect on a new Netflix
show like wow it's really cool how they
did that I want to try doing that it
doesn't mean that that becomes your
style but but you try it and I think
that gets you yeah I think that gets you
80% of the way yeah and then you see did
I did I enjoy that right yeah ultimately
you can't just be a copy because then
you're just a junior version of somebody
else exactly yeah but it gets you 80% of
the way yeah this is great clip that we
had and
a 50-cent top-10 where people were
submitting 50 cent now puts on other
artists like he produces other artists
and some people are submitting their
demos to him and he said man you're like
you sound just like Lil Wayne I'm
exactly like Lil Wayne Mike felt like
you had little Wayne here and this guy
and I close my eyes like the same guy
but we'd have a little Wayne exactly
except we don't need a your little Wayne
impersonator yeah we don't need a little
winning yeah but all the stuff that you
learned by copying little Wayne now you
need to find that final 20% to make it
your own
yeah and so that's where people
ultimately will find success and so
people people message me all the time
like hey this guy copied your top 10
idea okay great I spend zero time
thinking about people who are copying
yes stuff it's only forward-looking
never rearview mirror
so looking backwards yeah but for them
to win if they're just doing them if
they're just copying me they're good
they're gonna lose because you can't out
Evan Evan yeah you got to find your own
thing you have to yeah so if you're
gonna make your your own top ten rules
video awesome you need to bring
something different to it otherwise
you're gonna lose yeah yeah especially
if you're like copying like for example
Spielberg if a Spielberg idea comes out
you're always gonna be junior Spielberg
it's always gonna go to Spielberg you
know it's never been you're always gonna
be that person underneath somebody else
right or an Elvis impersonator exactly
yeah you're an Elvis impersonator
exactly and you can still make money
Elvis impersonators make money on you
can yeah the best Elvis impersonators
get jobs and make Nana you can get jobs
you can you can you could be the best
copy-cat but I just feel like it's like
but it's not out it's not you it's not
it's not but it's a piece of you but you
they haven't done the work to find the
final 20 years okay yeah so so I love
the idea of copying at the beginning but
then then you you have to figure out a
way to make it your own find a fine line
between copy and influence would you say
well I just flat out copy somebody it
won't it won't move the needle like an
original idea would but you're the
original is
just a tweak of a copy yeah right so
whether you call a copy or influence
well I mean like like for me but if I
saw a shot that I saw and like a Netflix
TV series something that I like yeah I
try to copy it yeah by saying oh he used
the jib and then they used this kind of
color palette and then right at this and
that this I do it exactly the same type
of skeleton almost I'd take oh this is
what I need the tools to do and I'll do
it but at the end of the day how I apply
to my story is that is that other 20%
yeah goes and the speed it runs and and
how I direct the actors are two
different things
right and I think that's the twenty
percent whereas I think you're talking
to eighty percent is okay what tools do
I need how do I do it and how do I plot
not and just the idea yes oh yeah oh
yeah gelatin coming out of oh yeah back
room that's cool that's cool yeah I'm
gonna do that with one green eye you
know yeah let's try that how did they
make that green I float imaginary dragon
behind I think the other thing that can
really help is when you understand so I
call a one word but or your value when
you bring that to your your craft
whatever you're selling it makes a
difference because you want people to
feel an emotion when they're working
with your business not just buying an
end result that's very important so so
for me it's believed all of my content
is believed is positive you could
somebody could try to copy the way that
I do things but they can't because they
don't feel they don't feel the thing
that I feel when I'm making my videos
you feel your thing
great you can copy the technique but you
can't copy the heart behind it so that's
why we're always fall short cuz you have
to find your heart because if you're
singing a little Wayne song the little
Wayne will sing it way better because
he's got the heart because those words
mean something to you or to him well to
you you just copying somebody else yeah
you can't fully copy somebody's value
over their heart over so the series that
Danny's making for me called becoming
his one word has become and it's trying
to tell the story of people who are
trying to become something more
something greater something better and
so that is the magic sauce that only
then you can bring that nobody else can
yeah so you should watch his video
and feel like you want to become more
yeah that's a success for Danny we're
four other people that that's not the
benchmark awesome so figure out what it
is that you stand for and then are
people feeling that in every interaction
every time the email you they see your
social media content they interact with
somebody on your team they buy your
product they look at your product
they're using your service but you want
them to feel something and when you can
figure that out when when they have an
emotion attached to working with your
company that's when you actually really
start to win and send out versus your
editors I think yourself when you've got
fear that's a little question how'd it
be yourself when you got fear that's a
long like that's a question to be honest
I the heavy hitting questions in the
Danny Neville I find her I find a way to
express myself in any way that I can
whether that's by myself writing into it
like a journal whether that's recording
myself and IG and telling a story
whatever it is I think you have to find
time for yourself I think when you find
way to be a way to be more comfortable
with just with yourself you begin to
discover yourself a little bit more and
it kind of slowly kind of picks away at
that fear for me like when I was growing
up I grew up with a lot of fear like I
hated who I was you know and and so for
me I wrote a lot okay and I had this
giant like journal on my computer or on
a piece of paper like whatever was there
and it says soulful to me at that point
I would just write and sometimes it
won't make sense it won't be about my
day necessarily but just about my
emotions and and how I feel right and it
wouldn't make any sense and I go back to
and I'd be like wow like I thought those
things like that's crazy but it really
helped me discover myself what was one
of the ones that you you look back and
say wow I thought that that was crazy
oh man I had on one on a piece of paper
which I don't think I have anymore okay
but it was really really dark like it
was just like a lot of anger and a lot
of like frustration and like it was bad
said they're like how could someone
break my heart like this and then and be
like you know I'd be talking about what
if I disappeared and like
no one would ever miss me and stuff like
it just really really dark okay and I
remember I look back and I'm like wow
look I could go there okay right so when
I look back and kind of discovered that
part of me like how am I feeling today
I'm not feeling that today but I can go
there yeah and I figured that up about
myself so then I kind of in that in that
sense of like learning about myself I
learn how to be a little bit more less
fearful of who I can because I think a
lot of times when you go that to those
dark areas you're half of it is shock
right it's come was like I can't believe
like these emotions like I can't believe
I'm in this situation I can't believe I
feel these things so when when you know
that you can you're more aware and
you're almost like almost more prepared
to kind of stop it before it happens
like ho hold on you're getting there
again like you're going there again oh
my god you're writing these words again
you know and you kind of find a way to
to kind of stop yourself and in a way
even if it's not stopped maybe perhaps
slow down the process or make it a
little bit easier for yourself and then
through time I think building up that
self-confidence you learn how to control
who you are both emotionally and
physically and when you learn how to
control who you are you learn to control
the fears and that that makes you more
comfortable being yourself and next
thing you know it's like I don't think
there's a one answer there isn't this
one thing that you can do like meditate
and fear is gone or workout and fear is
gone I think it's it's a process
somebody your process was to express
yourself process 6 psi my write it but
but do you feel like that just released
it like it was a way to get the the pain
or the the like anger out so it's not in
your system mmm or do you also feel like
it helped you grow and become better I
think it helped me grow for sure both
for sure I get the first one how did how
did the writing out like nope the world
would miss me or wouldn't miss me if I
was gone and how would how did that help
you grow I think just the fact that I
was able to like I said like I think I
looked at and I learned
like through time like maybe not at that
very moment that I wrote it but when I
look back I realized how dark I can be
right and how deep my mind can go that I
kind of told myself like I don't want to
feel that again but you look at you so
you so like say it's a year later yeah
you look back and say wow I can't even I
wrote that holy cow I've grown so much
since then I know I can go there and I'm
so grateful that I'm not there anymore
yeah so you have grown yeah that year
yeah but did the writing help you grow I
think if I didn't write it down I
wouldn't have that moment right you
wouldn't have you wouldn't have known
that you've made the growth possibly
yeah but that the writing facilitate the
growth you're not asking it kind of like
is to write it down what I'm trying to
give it is the expression actually
helping you like did it lead to you
growing mm-hm or is it just a benchmark
to say holy cow I have grown maybe it
isn't the thing yeah that helped me like
what helped you grow what helped you get
to a year later or five years that are
over long it was that you said holy cow
I'm not that person anymore
I think it's just through life
experience I mean it's like one of those
things we're like well you had positive
life experience it could have been it
could have been negative it right have
been worse like you might be in some in
a jailer right but so you see for me
like the reason why I wrote it down was
because a lot I didn't have anyone to
talk to
yeah at that time or I didn't trust
anybody yeah to talk to express those
feelings for with right yeah and I think
when you go with somebody that this is
even worse when you think you trust
somebody and you talk to them and they
either ridicule you or they don't listen
or they they make you feel smaller yeah
because you feel that way so for me
having those trust issues writing it
down yeah was the action that what the
what led to the growth like five years
later when you look back and say holy
cow I'm not that person anymore
what life experiences
jeez that's that's that's tough III
can't pinpoint anything you can't
pinpoint anything but all I know is that
like I looked back in I reread those
things so yeah maybe just the simple
action of writing it down kind of
journaling your journey in a way kind of
helped me I don't know if that answers
your question I'm not you know I'm just
curious so for me I didn't know where
you're gonna go with that question it
was exciting to pull that thread a bit
yeah I see the connection too
I think you need to have a valve to
release the pressure whether that's
writing whether that's singing or like
all the great music a lot of it comes
from moments of pain and frustration
yeah and they pour their heart out and
then they have this amazing song or it's
video editing or whatever I think I
don't know how much that helps you solve
that problem and grow but having it
release is definitely helpful for me
overcoming fear starts with the action
okay you do something yeah and so I I
have an expression where I try to
inoculate myself against judgment and
not callate yourself against judgment so
it's usually not fear that it's not fear
of doing something that's fear of doing
something in front of somebody else it's
fear of failure it's feel being judged
by somebody else and so the more that
you can catch yourself playing small
based off of somebody else's opinion or
potential opinion of you then you have
to go off and do that thing or think so
many entrepreneurs have these big
visions what they want to do but they
can't even do like this simple thing so
as an example filming in public there's
a guy Instagram follower of mine who
posted a video and tagged me where he's
at a grocery store it's like one of my
mentors Evan challenged me to film out
in public and I'm I'm terrified of this
so here I am doing it whoo right and and
it was it was good I mean it's the
greatest thing of all time no did it
suck no but more important is releasing
like you've done it yeah when you've
done it then you can do it again yeah
you can do it again you get better and
if you filmed every day the grocery
store
or he would get better but I have a
question about that yeah so if somebody
does that right just because they say
just because in their head because you
told them to do it okay
do they still grab value from that if
they don't fully understand why they're
doing to them it's just embarrassing
themselves you know like I'm gonna go do
it because haven't pushed me to do it in
the morning show but I don't know why
I'm doing this I'm just doing it because
he told me to do it and I just feel all
those feelings of embarrassment do well
I think I'm still valuable if somebody's
doing something because I told them to
do it but they don't understand the
connection then I suck okay okay okay
Danny go do this yeah it'll help you and
you don't know how it's gonna help you
then I suck right now
to be fair I might even I might throw
that in occasionally with like Alex or
something else like I might actually
give you that just because but it's part
of an ongoing like we'll come back even
if you don't get it we'll come back to
it but not some person that is on
Instagram so it was it was for him he
wants to be a thought leader he wants to
be a speaker right but he's afraid of
getting front of the camera on sharing
his message and he can do it in his
condo or whatever but great you have to
be able to like how are you gonna speak
on a stage full of people 10,000 people
watching you if you can't speak into a
phone in the grocery store mm-hmm yeah
like you need to solve that problem
first yeah and you work your way up yeah
because if you get on that huge stage
you'll freeze up yeah and so I think I
think that is actually the answer it's
finding these little micro moments of
potential judgment and then going off
and doing that thing yeah I think that's
how you actually win it's going into the
weight room and lifting five pounds I'm
not trying to lift a thousand yeah so
for him it was talk to the grocery store
and he feels the win and celebrate the
effort not the result right like now was
it a great video no but he did it like
yes yeah it's amazing crediting yourself
even here when I first started filming
here at TDS we're in a mall people ask
is this a green screen it's not a green
screen all that here yeah
yeah just we just blur the background
yeah I don't say what why did you pick a
shopping mall as a green screen that's a
crazy cuz we're in a shopping mall green
screen but when I first started filming
in here too I remember being worried
about oh my gosh is people walking
behind me they can't hear me but they
see me filming video now I have to do it
if I ever feel that judgment that I have
to go off and do that thing even if I
don't care about that thing because
growing through the judgement is so
character building that it'll help you
tackle so many other problems in the
future
yeah yeah right like when I got my nails
painted yeah I did want to get my nails
painted yeah because I was worried about
judger and people thinking wow he got
his nails painted that I had to go get
my nails not it's not about the nails
it's about the fear of judgement exactly
and so you want to inoculate yourself
against judgement and so as soon as you
find yourself doubting yourself or
playing small because of how somebody is
going to react to you then you have to
go off and do that thing take action
towards that thing yeah you know you you
want to ask a girl out you want to go
for a phone number and you're you're
nervous or afraid and now you have to go
do it yeah if you don't like her anymore
yeah yeah yeah even if it's a major
rejection yeah you know right just do it
and then if she says no it's like yes I
don't know if it happens like that I
would do it that's how I would do it yes
cuz I did it because because because you
don't reward yourself for the effort
yeah sorry
you don't reward stuff for the for the
outcome it's the effort oh the only
thing that matters is the effort did you
keep putting the effort you will win so
people are worried they go ask the girl
out for their phone number and and she
says no and I go oh my god I feel like
crap yeah this is amazing I did the
scary thing right Nikki do it again if
you keep asking for photos you'll get
water right and you'll get better at it
and then you'll lose the fear of asking
somebody for their phone number or or
whatever XYZ mm-hmm even me doing this
tour yeah I'm afraid nobody's gonna show
up in these into the cities right and
then I got a do I got it not just little
once I got a repeat it every four days
for 90 days
yeah right yeah every four days for 90
days have to be
relive my nightmare but because I'm
afraid of that as soon as I caught it
here's the thing most of the time you
won't catch it
mm-hmm when my agent first said you
should do a paid tour the god I want to
do a paid tour like not everybody can
afford to come to an event and I'm
talking myself down from it mm-hmm but
then as soon as I caught that a good
chunk of the reason is I'm just afraid
like oh man so you knew right away now I
have to do yeah I have to do it because
when when is I think we subconsciously
play small you just play small by
default but when you catch yourself
playing small then what do you do yeah
that's super important yeah if you want
to ask the girl out but you don't ask
her out and you and it's because you're
afraid and you catch that you're afraid
now you're training yourself I'm the
kind of person who doesn't who doesn't
it was afraid and then doesn't take act
as a follow up and that's so dangerous
yeah yeah because that builds your
character which then and I don't have
rights if I'm afraid of something and I
catch it then I have to go off and do it
yeah yeah so I have to go off and do
this tour yeah I agree
so that's how you overcome the fear it's
through action I like the idea of also
having a ventilation system right of
having a whether it's writing or singing
or the next step should be tour or
breaking something or you know like what
it shows breaks too many things but yeah
don't hurt yourself or yourself or
others yeah yeah cardboard boxes pillows
feathers just to release it because it's
not healthy to just kind of keep it
inside and have that that poison but
then but an action like what are you
gonna do so that you're not afraid of
that thing anymore and then the more you
conquer those little fears it allows you
to conquer bigger and bigger and bigger
I don't think you're ever done I think I
think no whoever you look at they're
still afraid of something I don't think
you can ever not be fearful in your life
so I think you're always gonna have
fears you just able to conquer bigger
things yeah I just some people are
afraid to get out of bed so people great
to open the closet door yeah you know
and I know that people are afraid to
save their city you know or yeah right
yeah you just start being with a handle
bigger and bigger bigger if you want to
learn more go Danny's story and also
help him get to his hero Arnold
Schwarzenegger check out the video link
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
my one word has become I used to
struggle a lot with self identity and
I've always tried to become something
else